why did Nicholas Cage demand to choke
down a live cockroach and how did a
single villainous request up end
Spider-Man no way home these movies
could have been so much different
the expansive Fast and Furious action
franchise is full of tough Macho actors
but their egos are a little more fragile
than you might expect in the fate of the
Furious and other movies in the most
recent phase of the series stars Vin
Diesel Jason Statham and Dwayne The Rock
Johnson all share the same demand
according to the Wall Street Journal
they each refused to lose a fight diesel
is a producer on the mainline series The
Rock and Statham both produced their
spin-off Fast and Furious presents
Hobson Shaw and all three are big enough
stars that they have the power to
override the intentions of the
franchise's various screenwriters and
directors each has a stipulation in
their contract that prevents them from
ever losing a fight on screen or from
even taking too many blows in a single
fight before coming out on top if that
sounds like it would get in the way of
the story and action choreography it
does the action is explicitly
choreographed around these demands and
every hit they take is counted and
balanced out they thought this was going
to be a street fight one crew member
told the Wall Street Journal that one
scene in the fate and the Furious was
originally written to have the rock
lying down while Vin Diesel stood above
them the rock apparently had the scene
changed so that he would be sitting up
to avoid looking weak
it's hard to believe today but Alien 3
was once the most despised entry in the
franchise even director David Fincher
has disowned it but given where the
franchise has gone since Alien 3 is well
still a pretty bad movie but hardly the
worst
we've got our own little world out here
it ain't much
but it's ours one person who foresaw
where the franchise was headed and
didn't like it Ellen Ripley herself
Sigourney Weaver who heard through the
studio Grapevine that the alien
franchise was evolving into a spin-off
slash crossover series Alien vs Predator
while the eventual film didn't come out
until 2004 plans were already underway
as early as 1992. she wasn't happy
Weaver told London film and Comic-Con in
2015 I heard that fox was gonna do Alien
vs Predator which really depressed me
because I was very proud of the movies
while Weaver couldn't stop Fox she did
the next best thing demand Ripley die
though marred by a mediocre movie Ripley
sacrificed by plunging into a fiery
Inferno is one of the most heroic and
emotional deaths in movie history until
Weaver returned as Ripley's clone five
years later in Alien Resurrection
2014's action Blockbuster kingsman the
Secret Service tells the story of eggsy
a London youth who's recruited into a
secret spy organization Samuel L Jackson
plays the film's main villain a tech
billionaire who plans to fight global
warming by drastically reducing the
population of the planet by a lethal
Force Jackson is no stranger to making
requests on film sets and for Kingsmen
Jackson's unorthodox request was to give
his character a speech impediment which
wasn't present in the script or comic
I have trouble understanding you people
sometimes
y'all talk so funny as a child Jackson
had a stutter which he worked to
overcome as he grew up he knew from
first-hand experience that people with
speech impediments were often overlooked
and not taken seriously which he thought
would be an interesting Boon to a super
villain Jackson Drew's specific
inspiration from Kingsman screenwriter
Jane goldsman's husband chat show host
Jonathan Ross who has a lisp both
Goldman and director Matthew Vaughn were
against the idea but Jackson was
steadfast in his demand and eventually
won them over he told the independent
that comparing his character's lisp to
Mike Tyson's list is what eventually
convinced bond to let him do it I'm the
most brutal of Michigan most ruthless
Champion has ever been there's no one
could stop me the relationship between
Michelle Rodriguez is Letty Ortiz and
Vin Diesel's Dominic Dom Toretto is the
engine beneath the hood of The Fast and
Furious franchise but their love story
nearly crashed right out of the gate The
Fast and the Furious was set to feature
a love triangle between Dom Letty and
Paul Walker's Brian O'Connor it was a
formulaic but understandable Choice what
better way to create tension between two
dudes than fighting over a girl but in
Rodriguez's opinion it was absolutely
wrong according to the Daily Beast
Rodriguez said they just followed the
format without thinking about the
reality of it is it realistic for a
Latin girl who's with the alphaist of
the alpha meals to cheat on him with the
cute boy I had to put my foot down this
took herzba after all Rodriguez wasn't a
movie star at this point and Defiance
could have gotten her fired or even sued
thankfully she had an ally in the film's
star Vin Diesel she said Vin was the
first one to pull me to the side while I
was crying and he just looked at me and
said I got your back that was the
beginning of the Letty fairy tale and
what a fairy tale it was the franchise
earned a staggering 5 billion dollars
worldwide over its first eight
installments and behind all the money
and muscle cars is Dom and letty's love
story almost makes you want to write a
poem the big gimmick that made
Spider-Man no way home such a phenomenon
was the convergence of all the big
screen Spider-Man actors coming together
in the same movie what are like some of
the craziest villains that you guys have
fought seems you've met some of them
alongside the three Webheads no way home
also brought back the key villains from
past films including Willem dafoe's
version of the iconic Green Goblin much
of defoe's work is spent in the Art
House and independent worlds far away
from the big Blockbuster superhero fair
so there was no guarantee he'd want to
reprise the role
before agreeing to come back as the
super villain he had two demands for
director John Watts and Sony chair Amy
Pascal the first was that it needed to
be a substantial part not a cameo and
the second was that he had to be allowed
to do his own stunts both demands were
met and the movie was all the better for
it
when notorious partier Colin Farrell is
the most stable person on set you've got
problems
a fiend for mojitos while Michael Mann
and Jamie Foxx are both rumored to be
difficult they got along well enough
during collateral to earn Fox an Oscar
nomination however FOX also won an Oscar
that year for Rey and supposedly the ego
that came with it four Miami Vice Fox
reportedly demanded private jets a
bigger salary and to not shoot scenes on
boats or planes maybe he'd never seen
the 80s TV show that inspired the movie
things got really dicey when the
production moved to the Dominican
Republic where security was tight and
tensions were high one night a local
police officer allegedly approached the
set and pulled a gun on a guard who shot
him that was enough for Fox who bounced
with his Entourage never to return one
crew member told slate Jaime basically
changed the whole movie in one stroke
man had endings planned for Paraguay and
Miami but Fox's Retreat to the states
forced his hand for his part man said
via slate it was like turning an oil
tanker around on a dime let the Miami
ending worked out to be the better
ending
cool world is a half animated Half-Life
action film that tells the messy story
of a jailed artist who creates a cartoon
reality that he can escape into in
classic Femme Fatale fashion a powerful
tune Hollywood seduces and manipulates
the cartoonist while a cartoon world
Lawman tries to stop them from having
sex which would turn her into a human
according to this movie's strange logic
though cool world was released a full
four years after Who Framed Roger Rabbit
the blending of animation and live
action isn't executed to anywhere near
the same level of quality even more
pressing than any technical troubles
however are the plot and tonal issues
which can be attributed directly to Kim
Basinger who played Hollywood director
Ralph bakshi was known for his
underground animated films aimed at
adults with cool world fact she was
going for another R rating but Basinger
demanded the movie be family friendly
with her specifically wanting to show it
to hospitalized children Paramount
agreed with Basinger but settled for a
PG-13 instead of the PG she was looking
for toning down the sexually charged
plot meant heavily rewriting the script
which was done without bakshi's
permission he hated the whole ordeal and
even physically attacked the producer
who did the rewrite Perhaps it is time
to pursue other avenues right let's hit
the bricks
legend of the drunken masters in 1994
Kung Fu Extravaganza from the one and
only Jackie Chan the film is actually a
sequel to 1978's Drunken Master which
was an early star-making role for Chan
he again plays Wang FEI Hong the real
martial artist and Chinese folk hero
who's been the subject of nearly 100
different films the original film was
directed by the legendary Yan Wu ping
but Chan wasn't 100 satisfied with the
results for the belated sequel a new
director was brought on board but Chan
was even less satisfied with his
Direction his biggest issues were in
regards to the execution of the action
sequences which tan intended to be an
antidote to the wire work and special
effects heavy action that was popular in
Hong Kong at the time Chan also took
issue with the presentation of his
character drinking as something to be
lionized as he feared the impact it
would have on impressionable young
viewers
yeah
as tensions grew behind the scenes Chan
wound up getting the director fired and
subsequently took over as the Director
about halfway through shooting
Marlon Brando was one of the most famous
actors to ever live and played an
important part in changing up the style
of acting back in the 1950s he was an
undeniably talented icon but at a
certain point he became arguably more
trouble to work with than he was worth
his Renegade behavior and constant
demands gave headaches to plenty of the
filmmakers he worked with one of the
films he caused the most trouble on was
the Missouri breaks this 1976 Western
Stars Jack Nicholson as a horse thief
and Brando is a man hired to hunt him
down according to the guardian director
Arthur Penn caved to every demand made
by Brando who spent the entire
production completely off the rails
Brando disregarded the script entirely
instead improvising his dialogue
characterization and wardrobe with
little Rhyme or Reason or even
consistency
ladies and gentlemen excuse me but I'm
under a severe attack from a tooth he
adopts an accent for some scenes while
forgetting it in others rotates through
an entire gallery of ridiculous hats and
costumes and even changes up his
character's entire identity and
personality between scenes when viewing
the Missouri breaks it feels less like
you're watching a western story and more
like you're watching the uncontrollable
whims of an eccentric actor to whom
nobody said no always finished right
and uh
I don't give a damn whether or not get
paid
Man on the Moon is a biopic on comedian
and performance artist Andy Kaufman made
by two-time oscar-winning director
milosh Foreman Kaufman was a larger than
life personality and filling his shoes
was sure to be a tall order no matter
who took on the role Jim Carrey turned
in an extraordinary performance and even
took home a Golden Globe for his work
but there were significant unforeseeable
costs incurred by his approach to the
role Kerry took a hardcore method acting
approach to the role of Kaufman which
also meant inhabiting Tony Clifton a
Persona occasionally adopted by Kaufman
Carrie is both Kaufman and Clifton made
constant unreasonable demands and
remained in character for almost the
entire duration of the four-month shoot
you'll start now when Andy steps in I
mean me I stepped in
he demanded that he only be addressed by
his characters names and generally
caused Chaos on set that foreman did his
best to straighten out the volume of
Carrie's uncontrollable Antics on set
was so substantial that that they
warranted an entire feature-length
documentary Jim and dandy the great
beyond released nearly two decades later
some of his craziest Antics included
forcing people to fight him off camera
getting a convertible only to
immediately crash it on purpose and
interacting with Kaufman's actual family
while saying he really was Kaufman's
spirit in Carrie's body what are we
gonna do I know
from acclaimed German filmmaker Werner
Herzog Aguirre the wrath of God is a
historical epic about a group of
conquistadors in search of El Dorado
Klaus Kinski stars as the title
character and he and Herzog would wind
up working together as director and star
on four additional films though they
nearly killed each other on this first
outing Kinski has a reputation as a
fantastic performer but also as an
exceptionally incendiary individual he
was known to be volatile destructive and
violent on and off of film sets Herzog
and Kinski had an explosive love-hate
relationship that saw near constant
screaming and physical attacks on their
film sets as chronicled in herzog's
documentary my best fiend Herzog
described Kinski as obsessed with money
and on their first collaboration Aguirre
he took up a full third of the budget
with his salary alone after shooting in
the Amazon jungle had wrapped Kinski was
needed to record some automated dialogue
replacement lines because he hated the
film Kinski demanded 1 million dollars
for one and a half days of ADR when he
knew the budget had run dry and Herzog
himself was flat broke at the time this
demand forced Herzog to Loop some of the
Geary's lines with a voice actor doing a
Kinski impression
following up the successful first movie
The Expendables 2 was an even bigger
Smash Hit success at the box office just
like the previous outing the big selling
point of the sequel is the massive
collection of action Stars
and back
most of the cast of the original
returned and new additions to the cast
were made with the likes of Jean-Claude
Van Damme Scott Adkins and of course
Chuck Norris Norris hadn't appeared in a
movie in the better part of a decade and
it had been even longer since he starred
in a film that didn't go straight to
video or air on TV after reading the
script Norris had one major demand
before he would agree to sign on to the
project it might sound like his
priorities are out of whack but Norris
is apparently fine with murdering
countless people on screen but refuses
to be part of the film that includes
swear words in an interview with Polish
publication kazeta he said I don't play
in movies like this due to that I said I
won't be a part of that if the hardcore
language is not erased producers
accepted my conditions and the movie
will be classified in the category of
PG-13 this ended up only being half true
the explicit swearing was removed as
Norris demanded but the movie was still
rated R for copious amounts of violence
the next sequel actually was rated PG-13
after much of the blood check was
removed
Sydney lumet's 1975 Heist film is an
enduring classic of the genre While most
bank robbery movies focus on intricate
plotting suspense and action Dog Day
Afternoon takes a decidedly different
approach based on a true story the film
displays a commendable commitment to
naturalism and is all about the
interpersonal drama of those involved in
the robbery he wants to kill me so bad
he can taste it
after three weeks of rehearsals to
explore the character and become
comfortable in the role Al Pacino felt
like he still didn't have it nailed down
when the first day of shooting was in
the can and they were looking at rushes
Pacino knew he had a major request to
make he wanted to throw out everything
they already shot and start over from
scratch a night of hard drinking LED
Pacino to the key to why his performance
wasn't working his classes Sonny was
supposed to wear glasses throughout the
film but Pacino wanted to ditch them as
was recalled in his biography Al Pacino
a life on the wire Pacino said no hold
it he wouldn't be wearing glasses
ordinarily he would but on the day of
the heist he would have forgotten them
because subconsciously he wanted to get
caught demanding to reshoot an entire
day's work for a seemingly Minor
costuming Detail couldn't have been an
easy sell but pachino's reasoning struck
true with lumet and the glasses were
left out of the film entirely and the
first day was reshot Vampire's Kiss
tells the story of The businessman's
Descent into to see after he thinks he's
bitten by a vampire and is slowly
transforming into one the film is most
notable for containing one of the
absolute zaniest Nicholas Cage
performances in a career chalk full of
Bonkers off-the-wall performances I
couldn't think of a more horrible job if
I wanted to
and you have to do it in one scene cage
was initially supposed to down some raw
eggs but he didn't think that went far
enough to shock audiences cage wanted to
swap out the eggs for a cockroach and
demanded that it'd be a real live
cockroach instead of a prop the director
relented and cage ended up eating two
cockroaches on set Cage also demanded
that he'd get bit by a live bat on
camera he fought hard to get an actual
bat but they proved impossible to
control and potentially lethal so cage
didn't have his demand met on that one
the making of Francis Ford Coppola's
1979 War film Apocalypse Now was a
notoriously Torrid Affair of the films
films Myriad problems one of the most
chaotic was Marlon Brando who was cast
in the brief but pivotal role of Colonel
Kurtz Coppola and Brando had earlier
worked together on The Godfather where
Brando was already making unprofessional
demands like making co-star Robert
Duvall hold his cue cards and scenes
together when it came time to make
Apocalypse Now Brando's demands grew
even more unruly he refused to read the
script or the book that it was based on
and demanded he be allowed to improvise
all of his dialogue power
and moral Terror
are your friends he also showed up to
set weighing significantly more than he
was supposed to after promising he would
lose weight before shooting blindsiding
Coppola given that his character was
meant to be living in austere life in
the jungle didn't add up for him to be
obese which meant Coppola had to shoot
him mostly in close-ups and in almost
total darkness Brando also refused to
shave his head at first but Coppola was
able to talk him into that one years
later Brando demanded 2 million dollars
to give an interview in the making of
documentary saying that Coppola owed him
it
David Frankel's The Devil Wears Prada is
a 2006 dramedy about a wannabe
journalist who takes the job as the
assistant to the notoriously difficult
head of a fashion magazine the role
ended up being one of Meryl Streep's
most popular of the decade and earned
her the 14th Oscar nomination of her
career everybody
the glowing reception of her performance
in particular might have turned out in a
different way if she hadn't made a
couple of major demands early on in the
creative process as reported in variety
Streep was interested in the project
when she was first approached but she
wasn't 100 sold on the screenplay right
away the version of her character that
she was presented with felt a bit like a
hollow cartoonish villain where his
Streep required the part to have more
depth than Nuance she demanded that two
new scenes be added to the film one of
which was a monologue from her to
Hathaway's character and the other was a
quieter and more emotional scene sounds
makeup that offered a peek behind the
curtain and discussed her divorce Streep
explained I also wanted a scene where
she is without her armor the unpeeled
scene in the hotel room just to see that
face without its protective glaze to
Glimpse the woman in the businesswoman
is there anything else I can do
[Music]
the Shawshank Redemption raked in the
Oscar nominations and holds the distinct
honor of being the number one highest
rated movie of all time on IMDb the film
is an adaptation of the Stephen King
Novella Rita Hayworth and Shawshank
Redemption and tells the story of an
innocent man who's sent to prison for
murder his friendship with an older
inmate and his eventual escape attempt
by tunneling out of his cell Morgan
Freeman had a couple of hard-line
stipulations during the making of the
Shawshank Redemption at first he nearly
turned down the role after reading a
single page of the book when he saw his
character was Irish when he was
convinced to embrace the ethnicity
switch he still had an issue with one
scene in the script the ending the
original final scene of the film was
supposed to feature Freeman on the beach
playing the harmonica that Tim Robbins
character had given him but Freeman
demanded the scene be changed he told
New York daily news that he considered
the scene asinine and cliched he also
refused to do as many takes as director
Frank Darabont wanted and tried to get
them to change the film's title to
include the men mention of Rita Hayworth
to match the full title of King's
Novella Darabont gave in and cut the
harmonica bit from the ending but the
shortened version of the title stuck
around
American History X is a 1998 drama about
a Neo-Nazi who changes his ways after
stint in prison and makes an effort to
reform his little brother before he's
irreparably stuck in the same
destructive mindset this drama was the
fourth feature film of Edward Norton's
career and it proved to be a defining
role and earned him an Academy Award
nomination however Norton's impressive
performance came with some baggage
behind the scenes he was only credited
as an actor in American History X but
Norton's involvement ran much deeper at
the time of filming Norton had a
reputation for taking over Productions
and making major creative demands that
his directors didn't always agree with
this was the case between Norton and
director Tony K as well norn did Heavy
rewriting on the script which was mostly
done with his director's blessing but
norn's demands intensified once they
reached post-production Norton convinced
distributor new line Cinema to let him
oversee an alternate edit of the film
without K which wound up being the
officially released version SK explained
in an op-ed for the guardian the studio
Grand Norton's every demand and began
disregarding Kate because Norton was
much better at articulating his opinions
I came in here to tell you one thing I
am out
their behind the scenes Feud boiled to
explosive Heights with K going as far as
to try to get his name taken off the
final film because it was no longer his
vision by the time Norton was finished